Neil Simon is our next presenter who
while waiting backstage to get on
tonight wrote a new play goes into
rehearsal tomorrow he was incredible I
think he is America's premier playwright
and screenwriters and it's nice to have
him here tonight would you welcome neil
better known as Doc Simon
I just had to take care of some personal
business first I I wanted to call from
my car it's number 211 otherwise I'm out
there before in the morning I know the
nominees for the best screenplay written
directly for the screen are all that
jazz story and screenplay by Robert Alan
Arthur and Bob Fosse and justice for all
story and screenplay by Valerie Curtin
and Barry Levinson Breaking Away story
and screenplay by Steve tesage
the China Syndrome story and screenplay
by my Gradius cook and James Bridges
Manhattan story and screenplay by Woody
Allen and Marshall Brickman
when there's Steve tesage for Breaking
Away
where's Sam I need Sam up here God
there's absolutely nothing I love as
much as writing to get an award for
doing something you love it seems like a
luxury I never expected I was gonna do
original stuff because it's and it seems
like this is it there's a tradition here
of thanking people and I think I will do
that instead Sam Cohen without him I
would not be here at all
Peter Yates without him the screenplay
would not have been written it would not
have been written as well and it
certainly wouldn't have looked like it
did
let's see there's Garrett Wiggin oh my
god I'm getting to the past and present
of studios like Benton did Alan Ladd the
present Fox people the last thing I want
to say is that long before I actually
saw America my first glimpses of it
we're in a movie house in Yugoslavia it
was a Western stagecoach and it seemed
like wonderful endless frontier of a
country where these good and evil
characters fought it out for the soul of
America and after all these years of
being here I'm just so grateful to be
given an opportunity to send back a film
and to tell him that I find it very much
like the place I had seen and originally
the good and the bad still fight it out
the good still tend to win in the end
thank you very much
the nominees for the best screenplay
based on material from another medium
are Apocalypse Now screenplay by John
Milius and Francis Coppola Kramer vs
Kramer screenplay by Robert Benton
LoCascio foe screenplay in adaptation by
Francis V bear Edouard Molinaro Michelle
O'Donnell and Jean Parr a a little
romance screenplay by Allan burns Norma
Rae screenplay by r Irving ravage and
Harriet Frank jr.
Robert Benton Kramer vs Kramer
thank you all very much this really is
one of the five best days of my whole
life thank you